stop
get off it
[Music]
stop police
stop police put your hands up
put your hands up man we just didn't
talk
stop
show me your hands
let's just talk okay
keep your hands out of your pocket
please all right you want to talk to me
turn off for a second sit down
okay sit down
all right
two seven we stopped we're on the south
end of
costco
all right just turn around real quick
yes no you're detained right now shoot
me quickly
no i'm gonna stop no yes why come on
let's just talk no
shoot me
stop dude just shoot me stop please dude
let's talk no sit down what happened
please what happened if it's here hands
on your back no hands behind your back
please just shoot me hands behind your
back please no i'm not going to shoot
you yes
dude come here let's just talk i want to
die i'm suicidal okay i can get you home
hospital you want to go to hospital yes
okay come here
sit down we're going to talk
let's just
sit right here bro
we're going to
talk right now
[Music]
no
[Applause]
stop
that goat is gone
now i'm gonna kill myself
[Applause]
let's go
let go
kill me
stop kill me
stop let go
kill me please let go please kill me
okay
please just kill me
good
you